I get to spend my days talking to people
that genuinely want to make the lives of
their customers their employees their
peers better and that's internally
externally and I get to be part of
brainstorming and delivering you know
ways that they can solve it not
everything I can't solve all of the
world's problems daylight cannot solve
all the world's problems but within the
realm we can we get to make an impact
every day and see things built every
single day that that that's enough to
get you up excited you know every single
morning welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
I am really excited to have you here
talking about people processors
digitalization daylight such an awesome
name for a company by the way as a
co-founder is you get a lot of the
credits to that so hey congrats on the
on building a fantastic companies
um and I love that that mission
statement builds digital experiences in
days not months with daylight tell me a
little bit about digital experiences
well what does that mean for you so so
for us it's really about the idea of
there's so many times where as a as a
consumer even as an employee you you
just want to interact with a business
and and you want it to be personal the
so the digital experiences are kind of a
um a way of representing those
interactions with a business a process a
product in a way that's more intuitive I
know it's gonna longer answer than you
probably expected but I always use
examples
um so you think of the entire tax
industry and you know there's tax
Regulators the IRS the CRA whoever they
are they have a business process but
it's it's terrible to interact with so
that whole tax industry exists to create
a better on-ramp a better experience
that's conversational that's intuitive
to actually provide your information and
ultimately file your taxes so that's
what a digital experience is and and
Daylight's focused on uh making it
accessible and making it so that every
organization can build that kind of an
experience in front of any of their
business processes
hmm okay so took me six years almost six
years ago the formation the formation of
daylight how did this whole thing come
about how do you even get into this
world how are you thinking about this
and how do you how are you thinking
about this in a scalable way that would
work for many businesses
sure well you know I if I if you really
really want to go back I'd say you have
to go back almost about 38 39 years now
uh when my when my partner and I met our
met each other uh at about five years
old
um uh in in a precursor to the the the
uh boy scouts or Cub Scouts if you're
familiar with those
um so we met then I believe we've we've
been friends you know on and off
throughout our lives and he's the one
that had this the initial spark but I
can tell his story on his behalf because
I've been doing you know he's my partner
in crime and uh partner in life so we we
uh you know we kind of know all these
these areas but for him the idea came
out of um what was actually a sad
experience he his wife
um you know they they lost a loved one
and they were at a funeral home dealing
with all the things you deal with when
you've lost someone and the funeral home
in question actually had a service that
they offered and it's a service where
they say hey we'll we'll interview you
about the person that you've lost find
out you know did they go to college or
university were they you know were they
an alumni where did they shop did they
collect you know reward points did they
have magazine subscriptions
and what they're doing is they're just
having a conversation with you but
they're using it and all these decisions
to say oh you went to college you
probably get the alumni you know credit
card or magazine and ultimately they
they when they're done the interview
they send you a packet a binder full of
all of the documentation that you would
need to transfer those miles to cancel
magazine subscriptions to deal with all
the things that follow you around after
you lose someone for years and years and
can be really painful and and what
they've done is they've put together
that binder with all the right forms you
know the little sticky notes of where to
sign it so that you can take care of it
in a single activity all the the
paperwork is an output of that
experience which was this conversation
and it was at that moment that Ryan our
CEO uh kind of looked at his wife and
and she knew he had an idea
um and it was because both he and I had
worked in healthcare in finance in other
areas and we had been Building Solutions
that we're digital you know better ways
as a marketer I was always building
better experiences to convert leads you
know on websites Ryan was working on
ways of generating tax documentation you
know
um police information whatever it was in
a repeatable way and he realized that if
you could build a platform where people
could do that same thing where they
could say here's the conversation and
the rules of the conversation that we
want to have and then here's the output
of the information however it needs to
be paper forms API calls then you would
have something and so again long answer
but that that was the Catalyst and and
it to tie it back to me Ryan came to me
eventually he asked for some help I
thought that he was uh looking for some
free labor
I was working on a few startups of my
own so I helped him a bit and I told my
wife about it and then he came back to
me a few months later and said all right
this is getting real you know we thought
I thought that my first interest would
be small business but they're large
Enterprises and I need someone to do
this with
um and so I went back to my wife and she
said this is a better idea than anything
you've had uh I believe in this and and
she's a conservative one in the family
you know she's very conservative but
she's like this is an amazing idea from
the moment you told me what Ryan was
working on I thought it was brilliant
you have to do this it doesn't matter
we'll make it work
um and so it was her vote of confidence
that caught me on board uh and it was my
my trust in my knowing of just how
brilliant Ryan was that that all you
know also sold me
and so tell me a little bit about this
identifying a process right if we're
looking at sort of the big picture here
um how do you define a process well how
do you even know what's a process here
that has the potential to be augmented
through through digital
so there's a few things I would say I I
don't know and you know I I say that to
our clients where
the people that we trust the people that
know it the most are the people that are
on the front lines in your organizations
they're the clients either demanding you
know calling up saying this is what I
want to do why is it so difficult or
it's the employees that are in your
branches that are your customer service
agents and your call centers who know uh
when when someone needs this this is
what I it says to do in the manual or in
the the handbook but here's what I
really do so most large organizations
insurers Banks pharmacies government the
processes are there it's not necessarily
that they need discovering the challenge
has been they have tens of thousands of
processes and their typical way of
getting them moving them forward has
been so slow and so dependent upon them
waiting in a queue for it or you know
building a massive budget to say please
solve mine of the ten thousand please
this is your mine
um so they know what they want to solve
they you know you can't talk to anyone
that works at a bank they're like oh
yeah it's just really annoying I have to
fill out all these forms because of The
Regulators or you know I have to I have
to do this seven times over or back and
forth for a week to get this solved so
any point where there's that interaction
between people and you know systems
whether they're whether that's a paper
Legacy process a green screen a modern
CRM or you know policy system you know
anything
all of those are processes and the
question that we ask and that our
customers are asking is is it intuitive
can I hire someone and have them do it
accurately the first time you know on
their first day here could I move it to
a customer who just wants to you know
add a the new child they had to their
policy do they will they know how to do
it are they gonna have to read through
jargon and rules and documents and have
that fear and anxiety like when you lost
a loved one that they're gonna do it
wrong that it's gonna come back to bite
them your you know vitamin the butt a
year later so there's no one process
that's right it's just all of these
points the knowledge is there can you
build the decision tree that asks the
right questions at the right time and
allows that person to do it and then
just deliver the data back to the
organization however they need it
whether it's as I said a paper document
a thousand paper documents or a modern
API calls straight through processing
that's an output the what daylight does
is it makes it allows those those teams
those those knowledge where workers the
people close to the problem to actually
build a better input
so tell me a little bit about the actual
product of what daily does sure I I kind
of call it
um I use a lot of analogies if you can't
tell already like I'm a story
um so there's a few things what you know
sometimes we refer to a low code
environment but I think that gets
confusing because there's there's a
whole category of low code platforms out
there
and we're not trying to replace software
development as a whole and that's what
the Mandate of some low code platforms
are
I the way I tell the quick analogy I
hopefully quick
um is think of it like blogging you know
daylight is more like a blogging engine
than it is a website builder and the
reason I say that is
we put real rails and guard rails around
what you build with daylight what you
build with daylight is a little bit like
a Vizio diagram
um a process map a decision tree so I'm
gonna ask these questions what's your
name where do you live and if you live
in this state here's my next set of
questions oh you live in Texas you know
please tell me about you know I don't
know some the ranch that you own oh you
live in uh none of it you know tell me
about
um you know the weather protection on
your house uh so you're building all
that you're building in daylight is the
rules of the process the questions you
ask the rules that determine what the
next question should be and then you're
configuring once I've collected the
right information where do I put it uh
and where do I deliver it so we're not
trying to recreate new data models new
um you know building a new database and
all these complexities of a full
application you're just building the the
knowledge you know that the things that
the chat checklist that someone does in
their brain the rules that the policy or
procedure mandates you do so as a
product that's what it looks like you're
kind of just simply mapping out here's
what I'm going to ask and then depending
on what they tell me here's what I'm
going to ask next and that may become
really complex uh if you're doing a
really complex claim or you're powering
a call center or maybe pretty simple it
may just say hey are you a corporation
or a sole proprietorship depending on
which one you are I'm gonna ask you some
more questions and then we're going to
help you you know file your
incorporation papers or file your your
new Amendment whatever whatever the
outcome of that process is
what what did you realize about the
world that that made this seem like a
viable business back then that this is
something that would be used by you know
many different clients many different
types of organizations from many
different use cases
I think there's there's probably two or
three things that I learned number one
so much of the world is still
ad hoc processes
um and and and we we sucked as a society
I'm sorry for the word but we were
terrible at the first phase of
digitization so we took sometimes what
was a good experience like an insurance
broker coming to your house and getting
to know you and your family helping you
you choose the right policy for you and
we we said okay let's digitize that I'm
gonna take all those forms that that
insurance broker ultimately filled out
and just recreate them online and say
here go have at it
um so so we didn't actually capture the
most important part of that experience
which was the relationship and the
knowledge that that broker had we we our
first thing was we took the outputs that
they did and said oh anyone can do that
but meanwhile that's not what the value
really was so I learned that I learned
that most organizations have so many
problems and they know what they want to
solve but when I talk to them they say
yeah we we've identified notified
you know this many problems
um but we can only solve this many and I
remember one that always stands out to
me is when they told me that we had an
amazing year everybody's so proud of
what we did but based off of the
problems we identified this year if it
takes us this long to do to solve each
one of them it's going to take us 13 and
a half years to solve the current
backlog and so so everyone you know it's
why it's some of these organizations
still feel so outdated is because
there's just so much to do and if they
keep going about it in the typical way
they just they just leave things behind
every year they solve the top the same
top 10 percent of you know Marquee
problems and then after three or four
years they're resolving that again and
those other things just get left behind
and then finally I'd say
I've learned that that whatever it says
in organizations you know and this goes
from my own organization whatever it
says in your your handbook your policy
your internet
your people actually know what it is
um and they're not always the same and
I'll tie that together by saying on the
very first project we worked on we got a
set of requirements from a bank so this
is a process that of how you transfer
your you know retirement savings from
One bank to ours and they asked us to
build a POC and the first thing Ryan
actually did this he went to the branch
and talked to some of the people at the
branch and said so this is what it says
what do you actually do and and to a
person they were they said oh yeah
that's what it says but you can't do it
that way otherwise it'll get rejected
like here's what we do when we actually
fill it out I never choose those options
I don't do it this way and we built that
directly into the experience for that
POC and that is really what led us to
win that very first massive Bank when we
were only two people big as a company
because
not only can our product and our
platform solve the problem we just
realized that like you just need to talk
to people and enable those people who
know it and take their knowledge and
embed that and you can you can get so
much more done um so anyway those are
three of the biggest things I learned
and it's the type of thing that gets me
excited every day to have conversations
like that learn about Industries learn
about you know experiences and and just
help make it better what did you learn
about sort of the messaging and the
positioning in front of the incumbent in
front of the
organizations that are getting
modernized and digitized what is the
what did you learn about the interaction
with them that may that make it more
helpful to integrate daylight into their
work or to get them to understand the
potential of what daylight can offer
them
that's a good question it's not done
yeah yeah we're still working on on on
improving how we communicate but there's
a few things
um one is
we we lived their role so Ryan was a
chief Innovation Chief security officer
I was a VP of marketing we worked in
healthcare highly regulated Industries
and
you know the skepticism that most of
them have is because they they're always
promised the moon you know by by vendors
by by companies and usually it's people
asking them to make a massive investment
and a promise that in three five years
this this machine learning
um is gonna pay off this new uh upgrade
of a core system is going to be so much
more effective in five years and they've
been burned by that because they know
either I'm not even gonna I'm not gonna
be in this role in five years when it
actually pays off so I'll get none of
the credit but I'll be blamed if it
doesn't work out for the next 10 years
um so what we talk about with them is we
tried to build our entire company to be
aligned to their goals which is can I
build something in a week or two that
solves eighty percent of the problem can
I see an Roi or an impact in days or
weeks instead of years and even at the
pricing level can we make it so that as
you're seeing more and more return and
you know we get a small piece of that
but it means we're both aligned to Pete
them actually getting things live and
when we have those kind of conversations
when we talk to them about how to use it
about you know when I talk to them on
the personal level about like uh when
you signed up at your organization how
long did it take you to get all the the
benefits to get all the the things what
was the experience like and and what
would you do to make that better when we
have those kind of conversations they
see the value they're still skeptical
but then it's usually in you know we
find ways to actually demonstrate our
value and that that's been a big driver
for our growth is is when they see it
and they realize that in the time that
the competing product or the thing they
had in-house is still scheduling the
meeting to talk about the problem they
have a thing that is live in a pilot or
in a a poc in those couple of weeks and
that that's when the team starts saying
hey this is something different we we
can we can do a lot here
interesting where do you get your own
inspiration and excitement over these
last six years doing what you're doing I
first of all I I I wake up like this
every day I just follow the energy so it
is partially it is just uh just a
genetic thing I I I'm an excited person
I I get my energy from from people and
ideas and I think Ryan and I share that
so
um every day I whether it's an internal
problem and I'm still obsessive around
you know asking people what can I do to
help you you know let's solve this
problem
um and the same thing with cios ctOS you
know heads of business units I get to
spend my days talking to people that
genuinely want to make the lives of
their customers their employees their
peers better and that's internally
externally and I get to be part of
brainstorming and delivering you know
ways that they can solve it not
everything I can't solve all of the
world's problems daylight cannot solve
all the world's problems but within the
realm we can we get to make an impact
every day and see things built every
single day that that that's enough to
get you up excited you know every single
morning
no no it sounds like it sounds like you
know what you're doing for the industry
and for knowing just in terms of
perception and the the ability to take
to take such a significant step function
um it's I think that that's really what
we're talking about here and finding a
way to do that didn't rather generic way
or in a scalable way like you're doing
with daylight
um I think that's it it's pretty it's
pretty incredible especially when it's
when you go 30 000 feet in there and you
realize look at this whole digitization
process and the different challenges
that are coming with it and the things
that are working the things that aren't
as working as well so I think this this
was very you know interesting for me to
hear about your own experience building
daylight and and figuring out how to
take these different processes and how
to meet the market and how to understand
the different challenges that these
different stakeholders are are having
the different promises they've had the
different things that they've faced
um so it's been a it's I've really
enjoyed these last 20 minutes and art I
really want to thank you for coming here
and congratulations on on building such
a great company over these last six
years to you and your your co-founder
and your other partners and uh thank you
again for being here for these 20
minutes I really loved it absolutely my
pleasure
[Music]